this morning an update on that deadly  six-car crash which shut down traffic  for several hours yesterday afternoon it  happened at the intersection of  washington and torrey pines metro says  an 18 year old was driving an suv and  speeding luther red light and smashed  into a driver making a turn into that  intersection and the driver of that car  33 year old woman was killed in the  crash set off a chain reaction the suv  crashed into three more cars pushing one  of those cars into a fourth vehicle two  of them caught fire  teen driver taken to the hospital with  serious injuries and is facing reckless  driving and dui charges